[Música]
continuamos con información en plan 24 y
le damos la bienvenida a consulta con el
especialista un espacio dedicado a
ofrecerles información importante del
contexto actual internacional casi todos
los sectores de la economía se han visto
afectados por la pandemia y sin duda uno
de los que sufre más en la industria de
la aviación nos acompaña el señor peter
cerda vicepresidente para las américas
de la asociación internacional de
transporte aéreo iata gracias por estar
en france 24 señor ser de cuéntenos
vamos a hablar un poco entonces de la
situación actual en cuanto han estimado
ustedes las pérdidas de las aerolíneas
debido al impacto del coi 19 cuántos
empleos se han perdido y cuál ha sido el
impacto en la familia directamente
relacionadas con este gremio bueno y
gracias por tenerme en el programa son
alrededor de 84 mil millones de dólares
lo que estimamos que la industria a
nivel global a nivel regional para las
compañías latinoamericanas son alrededor
de 4 mil millones de dólares que
perderán las compañías basadas en esta
región pero va más allá de sólo las
líneas aéreas
en riesgo que transportar yo no poder
volver a volar hay paro gobiernos y las
sociedades son la rueda de 4 millones de
trabajo que está en el riesgo que están
relacionados a la aviación y casi 98 mil
millones de dólares
hacia los pips nacionales de las
regiones en total que puede impactar si
el transporte aéreo no puede volver al
aire en américa latina de corto plazo
bueno señora cierta pero cuéntenos hasta
cuándo cree usted que podrían sobrevivir
las aerolíneas económicamente hablando
sin operar de manera normal
porque ya estamos en el 5 meses de
muchos de los países a nivel regional
que han parado las operaciones en otras
palabras nuestros países tienen
restricciones o en cerrar sus fronteras
la mayoría de compañías a nivel global
tiene un tres o cuatro meses de liquidez
para poder es ostentar una situación
parecida y ya llevamos aquí cinco y
vamos a estar en seis meses por esa
razón nos debemos de encontrar muchas
compañías de nuestra región se han visto
obligados a entrar al capítulo 11 de su
relación y tenemos otra media docena de
líneas de días que han parado de volar
total así que la situación ya llega un
punto que las líneas aéreas tienen que
recuperar en la operación y como usted
comprenderá hay muy pocas negocios a
nivel mundial que pueden sostenerse
cerradas durante seis meses y es la
situación que está viviendo la industria
aérea
bueno pero además varios países del
continente americano están comenzando a
reabrir los aeropuertos internacionales
tratando de reactivar un poco la
economía cuánto tomara volver a llegar a
los niveles de ocupación que había en
2019 y estarían los usuarios dispuestos
a volver a viajar normal y
tranquilamente
bueno primero hay varios países como
argentina paraguay que mantienen sus
fronteras cerradas colombia acaba de
anunciar que van a reactivar sus
operaciones el 1 de septiembre todavía
estamos esperando el decreto que se
firme por la presidencia de ese país es
muy importante ya que las fechas están
muy cercanas pero tenemos que empezar a
agilizar esas restricciones que tenemos
en perú por ejemplo se permiten los
vuelos domésticos pero no los
internacionales
lo que estamos estimando que la
recuperación de la industria en américa
latina' no se va a llevar a cabo antes
del 2024 para vuelos internacionales
las operaciones domésticas estimamos que
en el 2023 esperamos que los vuelos
nacionales la recuperación a la cifra de
2019 lleguen antes después los vuelos
regionales y seguido por los vuelos
internacionales que nuevamente no
estimamos que vuelvan a las cifras que
teníamos previo a lakovic antes del 2024
la situación es complicada entonces y
como ya ustedes lo mencionaba en el caso
por ejemplo de perú que solamente
tenemos vuelos domésticos hay países que
mantienen los aeropuertos cerrados como
harán ustedes en estos casos por ejemplo
hablando en términos de conectividad
no es un grave programa para américa
latina porque transporte aéreo es el
modo de transporte más seguro más
eficiente no tenemos la misma
infraestructura que tiene europa y
américa
con relación a dos de la carretera
ferrocarril y transporte aéreo es el eje
de nuestro modo de transporte a nivel
regional así que es fundamental que los
gobiernos
no te permiso cuanto antes para
establecer esa conectividad que es tan
importante no sólo económicamente pero
social en nuestros ciudadanos en
nuestros países latinoamericanos
dependen de transporte aéreo para poder
comunicarse entre sus ciudades y los
países de la región
bueno pues estaremos atento de lo que
ocurra con ese sector la aviación uno de
los más golpeados por la pandemia de
kobe 19 agradecemos la presencia de
peter cerda vicepresidente para las
américas de la asociación internacional
de transporte aéreo iata quien tras 24
muchas gracias al señor será yo estoy
gracias por estar con nosotros continúen
con más en france24 punto com
[Música]